what's going on guys this is rob and uh
let's kind of get into the idea of
avengers forever 2022. um the main
avengers for every story is okay
honestly the avengers storyline is the
one that really matters the most but
what we're gonna do here is we're gonna
pick up with avengers issue number 50
colloquially known as avengers issue
number 750 because it's the 750th issue
that marvel has released in the entire
publication of the series now avengers
number 50 you guys might also recognize
from when we did that terrible world war
she-hulk story which the conclusion was
kind of part of that this is basically
everything else right so what this does
is this initially picks up with case art
which is kind of weird kj is a character
who's never really been relevant if
you've never heard of him that's fine
you're not missing out on anything he's
like marvel's version of tarzan but just
not just less interesting the thing
about this is that he had essentially
been sent on a mission by uh black
panther to essentially chart the history
of the avengers 1 million bc and the
reason why for those of you guys who
aren't familiar with that one of the
things that jason aaron did when he
started riding the avengers and is
actually something that's kind of
polarized the avengers fan base in a few
different ways he basically introduced
the avengers 1 million bc as basically
this avengers team that existed before
everybody else it really flies in the
face of just the entire avengers history
as we know it in marvel comics so in a
lot of ways it really is jason aaron
trying to rewrite the history of the
avengers in terms of where their powers
came from and who their members are and
i don't really know if it'll stick we
won't really know until after his run is
over if it's one of those things where
it's kind of referenced by a few writers
here and there but nobody ever does
anything with it well then that answers
our question but regardless during his
his mission where he's just kind of
traveling throughout the time stream
he's ultimately met by kid thanos now
this is not thanos from like the cosmic
ghost rider storyline in fact this is an
alternate reality that so we'll get more
into what that means as we get further
through this but if a fight kind of
breaks out between the two of them now
as you would expect kzar vs thanos this
guy's nowhere near on the level of
thanos and in fact he would have been
killed had it not been for the arrival
of the avengers 1 million vc so
obviously this is kazaar in the main
marvel universe just back at an earlier
point in time which makes sense because
if this is a mission he's going to
undertake for black panther might as
well start with their own earth and then
just kind of work outwards from there or
just kind of move forward from there so
the result of this is that in this fight
between the two you don't really see a
whole lot that goes on right instead you
kind of skip past that whole stupid
you know world war she whole conclusion
and then you ultimately get to basically
when they defeat him now the reality
here is we don't need to see the
avengers 1 million defeat kid thanos
because it wouldn't really be any
measure of a fight anyway and so he's
ultimately sent back to his own time
where i sent back to where it was that
he came from and that's really kind of
it right now one of the things to know
is that while the avengers sort of
celebrate for a moment and then
ultimately odin and phoenix look like
they get to get to knock in some boots
that what you actually have here is dr
doom watching everything now the cool
thing about this is this is not dr doom
as we know him instead he's actually met
by mephisto this is one of the other
parts of what it was that jason aaron
was doing is that when tony stark was
sent back in time to the early days of
human history and really around the time
of about a million years ago he
encountered mephisto what we didn't know
exactly at the time but what we learned
later on is that what mephisto was
trying to do was see the the thoughts of
like doubt into the mind of tony stark
and basically get him to turn against
his own heroes or his own friends once
he got back in time even oliver was
trying to convince tony stark there'd be
no way for him to return back to the
present timeline of course tony stark
did but the schemes of mephisto didn't
work right trying to bargain a deal with
with tony stark and so on and so forth
none of it worked at all instead what
goes on is that with mephisto basically
being around at this point in time he
starts to broker a deal with dr dim now
one of the things that we learn here is
that this version of dr doom is the doom
supreme he is the sorcerer supreme of
his own universe and in fact he's the
doom above all now whether or not that
means that he has some kind of higher
level cosmic ranking which i highly
doubt just given the fact that with
everything going on in the story he
could do what he wanted to with the
greatest of ease or if he calls himself
the doom above all because he's more
powerful than any other version of
doctor doom that exists out there in the
multiverse which is the most likely
answer the fact remains he is basically
the doom supreme and so the result of
this is he knows exactly how mephisto
functions now for those of you guys who
aren't necessarily familiar with how
mephisto works i would explain it here
but there's a much better example this
given later on in this story uh in fact
we'll kind of go over it here in a few
minutes but basically doom knows enough
to know you do not idly enter into a
deal with mephisto you don't just do it
willy nilly that you literally observe
all the different possibilities and
that's why the people the only people
who really make deals with mephisto
knowing that they shouldn't and and
basically get like a beneficial end out
of it are people like thanos or people
like dr strange or somebody like dr doom
who was either intelligent enough
experienced enough or wise enough to
know exactly how it is that mephisto is
going to try to modify the deal in his
own benefit as well as how to ensure
that can't be done and to get the deal
to work out in their own favor so that's
why you don't really see a whole lot of
people entering into into bargains with
mephisto but again we'll talk a little
bit more about that here uh here in a
minute the overall gist of this is that
the conversation between the two of
course is that doctor doom has no
interest in mephisto right he's like i
mean he knows who he is but he doesn't
really have any respect for him i
shouldn't say interest he has no respect
for mephisto and that the result of this
is that with doctor dooms saying like i
know exactly who you are i know exactly
what you're about mephisto just readily
admits i mean i've tried to do this i
don't know what it is about this earth
in this universe but for whatever reason
the heroes just can't be corrupted right
you just there's no conceivable way to
break their wills and to turn them they
always somehow make it out on top right
like they're all basically mary sues
but it's a cool thing right because it
kind of hits to this idea that there's
just something special about the marvel
of the maine marvel universe in marvel
comics now we as comic book readers know
it's because the stories they're writing
the heroes are usually always going to
come out on top it might take longer
than normal but they always will uh if
it was just some alternate reality out
there well then who really cares right
it just it's whatever happens happens
and it's never the main focus right but
it's like the star of the show and so
the result of that is it's it's one of
these things where mephisto kind of
having this conversation with doom
proposes this idea and he says one of
the things that i've learned here is
that for whatever reason because of just
how these heroes work or whatever they
have kind of these incorruptible wills
and in time they will start forming more
superhero teams this avengers 1 million
bc this is just the beginning it's going
to be more teams that are going to come
out of the woodwork as the millions of
years pass right as time goes on and of
course he's accurate because in the
present day a million years after this
conversation between doom and mephisto
you've got the avengers and the x-men
the fantastic four you've got all these
different superhero teams that exist out
there and so mephisto's right when he's
like that's what's going to happen so he
says if it can work for them if they can
unite themselves under a banner and
basically unify against the greatest of
evils and ultimately come out on top
then why can't it work for us why can't
we simply band together create our own
teams and go from there and so what you
end up doing is picking up with kazaar
as he's traveling forward through time
again and then is suddenly knocked off
course to some alternate planet in the
main marvel universe the reason for this
is because he's attacked by just some
guy now one thing to know here when it
comes to marvel comics this is one of
the things that's that jason aaron's
really hitting on in the nature of time
travel is really like branch universe
theory so for any one particular thing
that definitively happens there is an
infinite number of possibilities of that
thing happening differently so if you
take for example peter parker getting
the venom symbiote in secret wars 1984
that happened right that is a definitive
incontinuity event that took place in
marvel comics there's an infinite number
of universes out there based on how that
one thing could have happened
differently maybe the symbiote was not
fluid and maybe it was more uh rigid so
it looked more like an iron man suit
maybe the symbiote was like green
instead of black there's all different
kinds of possibilities that exist out
there as a quick bit of a sidetrack this
kind of goes into a little discussion
about like alternate timelines versus
alternate universes because a lot of you
guys have been asking me about that so i
figured we could probably throw it in
here maybe i'll make a bigger video on
that in a future point in time the short
and sweet answer to this is that an
alternate timeline is an event that
happens or a reality that comes into
existence because uh an event that
happened in the maine marvel universe
happened differently so going back to
our example of peter parker venom secret
wars 1984. say for example that venom
symbiote was blue that's an alternate
timeline because whatever it is that
took place in the creation of that
original symbiote did not lead to it
being black it led to it being blue so
that's an alternate timeline where that
happens everything else is still
basically the same it's just the color
of the symbiote is different so that
branched off i don't know
null changed his mind halfway through
creating the symbiotes and said let's
make them the all blue instead of the
all black i i have no idea but an
alternate universe or an alternate
reality holy separate kettle of beans
this is an instance where a universe
comes into existence as part of just the
creation of the larger multiverse and
does not have an origin point that's
tied to the main marvel universe itself
so if for example you had an alternate
reality out there where everybody was
animated that's an example of an
alternate reality that is not an
alternate timeline there's never been an
instance in the history of any of the
characters in the main marvel universe
at least as far as it being universe
wide where they were all animated and
then stopped being animated and somehow
that animated alternate universe is just
a continuation of what would have
happened had they stayed animated that's
never been the case and so that's just
an alternate universe that came into
existence that does not have a direct
tie to anything going on regarding the
main marvel universe itself so hopefully
that kind of clears that up but back
into the main story itself right i don't
want to dilly dally too long on that
back into the main story itself what you
have here is this guy of course who just
kind of shows up out of nowhere and
basically just gets into this great big
huge fight with kaizo and it's kind of a
cool thing here because what we're
actually gonna do is we're gonna we're
gonna back pedal here in a minute we're
gonna talk about robbie reyes because
he's really important but this fight
between the two is pretty significant
specifically because this guy is
actually revealed to be an alternate
reality version of howard stark now the
truth about this and what's kind of cool
is when it comes to these different evil
versions of characters from across the
multiverse this is probably one of the
only times in this whole story where we
actually get an origin for him
when i say the whole story i mean like
death hunters avengers forever that kind
of a thing we don't really get much of
an origin story for really any of the
other characters but the thing about
this is that we get this story for
howard stark where he was basically
howard stark as we knew him and an
alternate reality that he was the guy
who founded stark industries he founded
shield in a lot of ways his history
seems to be very similar to the history
of howard stark in the marvel cinematic
universe the biggest issue that howard
stark had and his biggest concern is
that he began to grow envious of his
children and he says he'd studied the
history of the earth's great powers the
legacies that had shaped the planet and
the starks deserve to be mentioned right
alongside all of them his big concern
here is that he was simply just a man
and what he wanted to do was to be able
to stand there and live through
everything that he had basically created
i mean it's a huge ego thing the guy's
obviously a massive narcissist and so
ultimately he was invited to what was
basically a street corner which that
doesn't seem shady hey let's have a
meeting somewhere meet me at this street
corner in a seedy part of new york uh
obviously that's gonna be a little weird
right so the thing about this when he
shows up you've got this homeless guy
covered in flies and for whatever reason
that's never really given to us howard
stark makes a deal with this guy now
it's kind of one of those weird things
where you could look at it and say okay
it's just jason aaron just being really
wishy-washy but it's actually not
because remember this is mephisto that
we're talking about here right mephisto
knows the souls of crooked men and he
knows howard stark it would not be that
hard for him to dupe howard stark tell
him everything he wants to hear and
basically say i can help you solidify
your legacy i can ensure that you will
live forever but remember mephisto
always asks for something in return he
will give you what you want but you have
to give him what he wants but there's
always a catch to the deal the bargain
that was made here is that in order for
howard stark to basically live forever
he's got to kill tony and he does he
literally kills tony in this alternate
reality when that happens he's not
immortal he was told he would be
immortal but he's not immortal the
reality here is that he does die and
when he dies he ends up traveling to the
realm of mephisto and then once he's
there he ends up basically building his
own suit of armor very similar in a way
that tony stark did it right in a cave
with a box of scraps you know that kind
of a thing but his immortality comes at
the price of the fact that he he does
not get to live to see his works come to
fruition in this alternate universe
instead he becomes the iron inquisitor
right the the chief security force of
the council of red basically ensuring
that their will is maintained right that
the idea is that these are guys right
all these different versions of mephisto
from across the multiverse who want to
rewrite the entire history of whole
universes basically like then reality to
their whim just rewrite uh the history
of universes the history of worlds and
then basically make everything their own
and that's the role he serves now
instead of being the guy that gets to
see his works come to their grand
fruition in the earth 411 universe he's
actually going across the multiverse and
ending other empires killing other
versions of himself or his own son
that's the price he pace now the thing
about this is that he basically tells
kazaar like you're not going to go back
to the avengers you're not going to
report to them but i can't kill you here
because if that happens it's going to
draw the attention of a whole bunch of
death locks if you don't know what that
means it won't be important until later
on so don't worry about it for this
particular story but if you do know what
it means you understand that it's cool
and kind of a big deal so the thing
about this is that howard stark is not
going to kill kazaar in the traditional
sense because it will draw all the
attention of these different death locks
and alert them to the fact that howard
stark is here the significance of that
and why that's an important thing again
we'll talk more about that once we get
into the death hunter storyline because
it's a very pivotal part of what's going
on with everything happening right now
this is really just kind of a opening
salvo to a degree instead what howard
stark does is he actually kind of pulls
a loki so if you guys remember from the
loki tv show when silvie was basically
altering the timeline but she was
masking her actions uh with essentially
cataclysmic events that's what's going
on here with howard stark that by taking
kazaar to some alternate planet in the
history of the main marvel universe
that's not going to alter the time
stream it's not going to do anything
that's going to change the timeline
because technically kzar's not supposed
to be here so so long as he doesn't
really interact with anybody and as long
as howard stark doesn't interact with
anybody no must no fuss once howard
stark basically teleports away the
khazar looks around and realizes this is
a world that's about to be consumed by
galactus so it's going to meet its
natural end galactus is going to consume
it destroy it and kazaar is supposedly
going to die along with it now one of
the things that goes on here and you can
tell me whether or not you think so you
think it matters is that kazaar
basically battles galactus for a minute
galactus and and when i say a minute i
mean like a hot minute like two seconds
galactus is kind of like hey i have
respect for you and then he turns him
into a herald so i don't know if that
matters to you or not it's a cool thing
kind of i guess whatever but the thing
about this is uh you kind of jump back
you jump back to doctor dew and what we
end up finding out is that in this kind
of momentary bit here that dr doom had
basically formed his own team right kind
of uh multiversal masters of evil don't
necessarily know if i like that name i'm
surprised marvel's still using the name
of masters of evil it really hasn't been
relevant since the old ultron stories
from back in the day but the thing about
this is that this group is basically
been tasked with traveling across the
multiverse and killing every single
version of avengers 1 million bc in that
alternate reality now here's the reason
why that matters that jason aaron had
largely been building up to this and we
didn't really know where he was going
with it that was a big question i had
what's the point of avengers 1 million
was it just to say that like a bunch of
people had been teaming up that unlike
pretty much all the history that we know
with black panther for example that like
machine gun was not the first black
panther that there was a black panther
before him which makes no sense
whatsoever because the entire reason
that black panthers came into existence
was to protect the great mound of
vibranium in wakanda which didn't land
until about 10 000 years ago so uh i
don't know how you square that circle
but the whole thing is is this was kind
of building up to this idea that what
the avengers 1 million bc did is kind of
set the framework for the age of heroes
that if there is no avengers 1 million
bc there will be no age of heroes now
how this will present itself the lack of
an age of heroes how this presents
itself actually changes from one reality
to the next that there's some instances
where you have whole universes or i'm
sorry a whole earth where it looks like
humanity just doesn't exist you've got
other ones where humanity's nowhere near
as advanced as it is so it really just
kind of changes obviously jason aaron is
building up the idea that the avengers 1
million serve an extremely important
role but in an alternate reality out
here in earth818 this is a particularly
important universe because this is
actually where the avengers forever 2022
story picks up in that you basically
have odin who's destroyed by kid thanos
and when odin is killed it's like the
first place that the uh the the
multiversal masters of evil basically
pick up at now for those of you guys who
are reading avengers forever 2022 and
we're also a little concerned about what
was going on with robbie reyes the
overall gist here is that robbie reyes
has just had these struggles sleeping
he's just been waking up from like these
really really harsh nightmares right his
energy or his powers or just kind of
getting getting carried away with him
right like it's almost like he's losing
himself and this is really you really
kind of required him to face his own
mortality that in the events of like
moon knight becoming the phoenix and
konshu and all that kind of stuff that
was also a part of it as well and so
what you end up finding out here is the
reason why robbie reyes powers are kind
of going nuts is because he's being
sought after as the omniversal avenger
by what are essentially or seem to be
the various death locks that are out
there the other thing that goes on is
that robbie reyes is actually snatched
away that he's basically yanked away
from this particular universe and is
sent to the earth 818 universe now this
like their arrival here is a million
years after the the multiversal masters
of evil had killed the avengers 1
million bc right so they're not still
lingering around it wasn't a battle that
just happened or anything like that a
lot of time has passed but this is one
of those depictions that are out there
where the death block basically says
like our you know our purpose here as
these death walks is to essentially
travel out according to the wishes of
avenger prime and grab those individuals
out there who stand the best possible
chance of defeating the multiversal
masters of evil right the absolute most
powerful and dangerous deadliest
villains who exist out there across the
multiverse but you end up having this
kind of depiction or this this
realization that in this alternate
reality earth 818 that this giant
landmass that they're sitting on it
should be manhattan but instead it's
just grasslands right it's just ground
there's nothing there nothing's been
developed so it's not as though it was
some rise of a great civilization that
inevitably destroyed itself because
there were no hero archetypes to show
them a better way instead humanity just
never evolved to that point and that was
basically it and so that basically seems
to be what it is that is what they're
really shooting for here now the other
part of the equation is mephisto that
what's most likely happening is the
masters of evil are basically taking out
avengers 1 million bc and that leaves
the door open for mephisto in that
reality to influence the world and when
that happens that's how you end up
having a mephisto who conquers that
world and so again it's a pretty cool
thing right it's a pretty cool uh
realization there of course in the
middle of all this they're basically
attacked you know out of nowhere by just
all these uh all these war machines
right we'll talk about that you know
later on uh in a different video but at
that point you basically switch over to
the main marvel universe when the
multiversal masters of evil arrive and
when they show up here the orb appears
kind of the weirdest selection by jason
aaron but it also kind of makes sense
right you know as the the guy who had a
major hand in in like the whole original
sin event when i say the event i mean
everything that went on with original
sin not just writing it but like having
a hand in how everything was organized
and structured remember the orb is the
one that took possession of one of the
watcher's eyes where nick fury was the
one who killed the watcher the orb used
the eye of the watcher to blast the
whole world with basically everybody's
secrets is how captain america realized
he was a part of the illuminati but his
mind was wiped and he was kicked out by
doctor strange at the request of tony
stark just all that stuff and so ever
since the death of the original watcher
in original sin before or at least going
oh my god going into jonathan hickman's
avengers news like during all that stuff
that the orb kind of became like a new
watcher to a degree where he literally
just oggles well he just stares and
ogles
that's it now of course the masters of
evil don't know what to make of this guy
they're like well what i mean how does
this guy talk like how like how does he
communicate he's just an eye like how
does this guy talk nobody understands
like nobody can grasp this guy and
they're really kind of like i mean this
is a little weird but because of the ore
remember the watcher sees everything on
a multiversal level so the orb is aware
of what it is the masters of evil have
been doing across the multiverse and so
he's really more curious about it than
anything else he's not really going to
try to stop them because his job is to
just watch is to not do anything so he's
like the watcher and so this is one of
those things where we're kind of given a
little bit of an explanation not a
full-on like just deep dive into who
each one of these guys are but you've
got doom supreme who we already knew
about you've got dark phoenix who will
learn more about because she's
ridiculously powerful you've got kid
thanos who you guys have already met
then you've got king killmonger
basically an alternate reality version
of eric killmonger that conquered both
wakanda and asgard yes he's every bit as
awesome as you think he is you've got
norman osborne the ghost goblin who's
pretty damn powerful and then you've got
venom who's basically uh the red skull
with the venom symbiote that they're all
incredibly evil twisted and ridiculously
powerful they kill they kill the orb and
rightfully so it's high time that guy
just just bit the bullet right just died
it's high time that he ate a bullet or
something man that guy just needed to go
but what this does here the way this
ends is it effectively sets the stage
for the beginning of two stories it sets
the stage for like if we go from here
directly into avengers the death hunters
it goes straight into that right segways
in perfectly the other thing it does is
it sets the stage for avengers forever
2022. now whether or not you guys
actually want me to cover avengers
forever 2022 let me know we are gonna do
death hunters the stories i've heard can
be read interchangeably i've also heard
that you have you kind of have to read
them one after the other so like
avengers 51 avengers forever number one
honestly i read them separate and i
didn't really feel like i was losing
anything so let me know what you guys
think will cover my separate videos or
whatever but uh yeah thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace